ever heard of golden handcuffs it
usually refers to perks that employers
dangle in front of employees in order to
keep them from straying to greener
pastures these perks often take the form
of equity compensation that's when
you're offered stock-based Assets in
addition to your normal salary in olden
days this sort of thing was reserved for
high fut and sea Suite Executives but
due to changes in tax laws they've
become more popular since the 1950s now
everyone from fast food joints to
grocery stores are offering employe away
into the equity game this type of
compensation can come in a bunch of
different forms and can be hard to
understand the tax implications are
especially weird so make sure that if
you have a significant amount of this
stuff you talk to a CPA but when you
want to figure out how to sell and
integrate the proceeds into your
financial ecosystem a cfp or certified
financial planner can help you there
trust us you're going to need some
expert help to avoid expensive mistakes
and make sure this Boon doesn't become a
bust